[Music]
we begin this half-hour with the world
of women's wrestling and lately that
means the whole globe in October the WWE
signed the first female pro wrestler
from the Arab world shadi Abasi so is a
Dubai based TV host CrossFit aficionado
and jujitsu blue belt holder women's
wrestling is also taking off in Japan
and it has also gone international with
a young American making her mark Adriana
Diaz has the story big sword slam and
swan dive
Japan's Pro women's wrestling is a
uniquely local blend babydoll fantasy
and unbridled aggression shattering the
stereotype of the docile Japanese woman
they express things that we cannot
express openly said this fan the
spectacle has drawn guest wrestlers from
around the world but one is unlike the
rest standing at just 4 feet 11 inches
tall New Jersey native Chris Hernandez
is the first foreigner to come up
through the Japanese ranks and go pro
what do you become
when you walk into the ring I feel like
I'm on fire I feel like every last part
of my being is exploding in the ring she
goes by her alter ego Chris wolf I eat
lots of meat and I do like to bark and
howl so I guess it just fits really yeah
yeah it's there all the time but Chris
wolf wasn't always so wild the 33 year
old college grad moved to Japan four
years ago after a bad breakup and
started teaching English then one day
she saw Japanese wrestling online and
wills hurt holy beep
sorry I have to censor myself or else
I'm gonna curse I thought I need to do
this and the fact that these girls were
flying through the air kicking each
other in the face and
dying was pretty impressive starting
from scratch it took months of weight
training and learning moves until she
was ready to debut what does her mom
think about this she hates it she's like
you are too educated for this she tells
me that how often every time we have a
conversation Fernandez says the rough
and tumble of Japanese wrestling is
harder hitting than in the US she's
often bruised and in near constant pain
even suffering a career pausing
concussion in 2015 unlike an America
where the theatrics are as rich as the
paychecks Hernandez earns just 250
dollars a week for the privilege of
getting pummeled this hasn't been easy
for you why do you continue I don't know
I still feel like I should I still like
I put in so much time just to debut
maybe if I can do this then I can tag
some other fool who's watching and make
them feel like they can do anything
anything to achieve a dream no matter
how outside the box or inside the roads
for CBS this morning Saturday Adriana
Diaz Tokyo I have a bruise just from
watching living the dream in Tokyo yay
good for her yeah